foreign
's here guys no big deal
by the way are any of these cameras on
me I'm like hey
um they're all on her I'm off camera oh
God please
um I've been kind of obsessed with you I
am so obsessed with you Whitney like
when you when I saw a DM from you like I
really almost shit my pants like I am
such a huge fan and watch every special
all your shows like I'm just yeah that's
so weird together and now we finally are
on a show together kind of but not
really kind of but not really but it
still counts as far as I'm concerned so
do you remember the time I think we did
meet once you might not have been there
where was it I was on a show called
punked oh my God and I did you do with
Adam Brody I did it to what's his name
Chuck
to um to Zachary Levi Chuck um no no Ben
McKenzie Ben McKenzie yes yes okay yeah
that's right so Adam did he Punk Ben I
have the worst memory known to man you
not uh uh yes and no yes and no that's
what people with great memories say to
throw them off the trail but you do but
you're you have this you only remember
things that are actually important yeah
yeah that's true this is not an
important this is not important I'm glad
you've been being possible lost respect
for you if you remember this look at you
I'm like yeah no no it was like it was
Adam bro I was like the waitress that
was hitting okay hitting on
Ian not Ian McKenzie Ben McKenna no
wrong wrong no Adam Brody was being
punked yes wrong did bro yes okay
hit on him and I was his girlfriend and
he was so rude he was so he was a dick
because but no he wasn't a dick but I
think Ashton probably intentionally when
he didn't Punk picked someone he knew
wouldn't like maybe knew their character
maybe Adam was so pissed about that that
I got punked later like my friends
punked me and it was is it but I also
think agents were involved I think maybe
agents started because it was such good
publicity for people it was a huge show
like when I did Chris Klein or something
yeah the agents gave us the keys to his
house we had a hostage crisis in his
house
holy shit you know what I mean so anyway
so yeah so so yeah Adam was so pissed
about it and then I got punked and he
got so mad that my friends let Ashton
Punk me my dog like rescue pit bull got
out and like caused a mail truck to
crash I was horrified my dog was like
locked up in this you know there is some
weird like I'm always big on I'm not the
like Trump's here to burn it all down
I'm not that guy yeah but I do think
that there's something to be set because
I think I'm just like
everything has to be for good or else I
I get to right um I don't get depressed
I get to like
um anxious you know because when I hear
that something like that happened to you
I get like upset because it works at you
but I think big picture what maybe
punked did was show
people that aren't celebrities that
celebrities are human beings right and
they get sad and they get scared and
they humanize it like it's yeah yeah
you're absolutely I did Kaylee like in
the moment I think it feels a little
inhumane like I did Jennifer Love Hewitt
Kaley Cuoco like the scenarios were so
like they handle it how did what how did
they handle it oh they were
um Kaley Cuoco's was like I mean she's
also the has the biggest heart of and
you know anyway
it was something about like some
homeless guy that was living in a van in
his van collapsed or like caught on fire
oh God outside of caudel Seoul that
restaurant yes and she was like she saw
it I was I played the valet oh my God
you know I was like the ballet which is
like I didn't even have a car at the
time it was so crazy I had to drive her
car bring it up to her and then I'm like
oh my god look what's happening she was
like balling crying she was like I'll
get you a hotel like she was like a
superhero same with Jennifer Love Hewitt
but it was like but I felt bad because
it was like Jennifer Love Hewitt's was
that
Mark Forster uh the direct really like
fancy director like called her in for a
meeting but it was like fake yeah you
know what I mean oh yeah that's me like
and that's like oh that's not really at
the end it's fine you know what I mean
but like Case by case but I think a lot
of them didn't air I heard someone
talking about it I don't know why we're
talking about punked again all of a
sudden I know well I mean it connected
us yes like 12 13 years ago but I always
thought Adam Brody was a dick because he
was such a dick to me when I was paid
500 to flirt with him he literally was
like no thank you no thank you
was dating you at the time well I guess
that makes me feel a little good you
know not to be a dick like he shouldn't
be it wasn't a dick or rude but I was
trying to get his I was I put my phone
number I remember this phone number is
my heart was fucking I was like I want
to end this he was so pissed they like
they tried to move seats but because the
cameras are hidden yeah Ben was like nah
dude let's just stay here it's fine
because bend it right so Ben obviously
was in on it oh yeah yeah Ben bottom to
this like weird like Lounge you know
you're unpunked when you go to a lounge
on Vine
like why would you ever in what world
are we eating at Marie calendar
me to actually do the podcast you know I
wrote a lot of scripts that Marie
Callender's on wheelchair I don't think
there's any left
I thought about this the other day House
of Pies is still there House of Pies is
still there but I don't know the Marie
Calendars it's not film will sure I
think there's one in the valley don't
you think that would make sense there
was one in Sherman Oaks it is a money
laundering Enterprise so if they shut it
down really I'm kidding yeah or anything
I'm like what um there's one on National
Boulevard okay and oh yeah in um not
Venice but National yeah like in really
in the city
um it's been a pleasure guys we're gonna
go to Marie yeah
so I know because you have
um uh I want to ask you a couple
questions about your podcast do you now
that you have one is it do you enjoy
being guests on other ones
yeah I mean I you know what's so funny
even on mine I'm always like a little
like oh what am I gonna talk about or
what you know I have to ask these
questions yeah I don't like love the
pressure of it but it always goes fine
like it's always fine so I can tell
myself the anxiety that I built build up
before it it's always okay and I think
that the anxiety helps you it does it'd
be weird if people that aren't anxious
at all are usually just like you're
gonna just air that right I think smart
people have anxiety and it makes us
Focus yeah like it's anxiety I think is
a really powerful tool that we've kind
of like you know
um like pathal over pathologized there's
anxiety conditions where you can't get
out of bed that's different right I have
anxiety yeah you're about to talk to
millions of people you should have a
little anxiety right weird if you did it
right you know yeah if you were so
comfortable but like coming today I was
really excited to come and talk to you
obviously because I love you and and you
know I wasn't anxious in the paralyzing
sense because it was excited I'm like
I'm going to use the anxiety because I'm
excited and that's what it is and also
like I mean you have a kid like
sometimes you just like want to play
with a new friend and that's kind of we
are doing it for public consumption
because we're finally figuring out how
to monetize like like just our brains
and conversations right you know yeah
and I like being so open and transparent
like my best friend on Broad ideas with
me we really go there and it's like you
should be able to talk about all the
shit that's taboo or like people don't
want to hear about it's like and guess
what happy to be wrong right I just my
thing is like
here's something I noticed take it or
leave it right I it's not my it's not
our job to solve it no we're like the
elders that are sharing our wisdom right
for the Next Generation because most
people's mom and dads are working and
they don't have time to constantly be
like this is how this works and this is
how this works and this is how a woman
gets pre you know what I mean right so
we're like yeah I find like in my 40s
you know it's just a different thing
I've actually have experienced so much
in life and in relationships and
everything else where you really feel
like I kind of have a handle on some
things ish always learning and the only
way that all the quote mistakes we made
it's only a mistake if you did it more
than once yeah otherwise it was just
right being a human being yeah
I feel like talking about stuff on Pi
this is why I love you know being a
comedian so much everything quote bad or
rough or painful that happened to me if
I can share about it and then other
people can learn from it it wasn't for
nothing right right it wasn't for
nothing that's the positive spin on it
yeah yeah like I feel like ah okay yeah
you know like I'm to the point where
anytime something like quote bad happens
to me I'm like yes dude fuck yeah I'm a
new story like I will I think actively
kind of seek weird conflict just to get
talk show stories because you'll have
yeah yeah we have to promote the accused
soon oh my God I know so Rachel and I
are on I don't know how the fuck I
conned Howard Gordon to uh get me in a
drama I'm a witch I am so excited to
watch your episode uh I'm so what are we
allowed to say what there are the
accused let's see if we can pitch it
right yeah we're pitching it um to a
network right now so this is a show
we're working on it is a um it's a it
was in a English format yes it was and
it was it's about like really
Poss it's about being in a pickle
I think that yep that's our pitch you
know when you're like in a gym yeah
but it's like not really your fault
you're not really your fault and about
how when you're in a jam
a little more evidence all the stuff
that's happening is so perfectly open to
interpretation to people that it's a
workshop test yeah and I'm really yes we
figure out it's hard to tell who's like
did you see the staircase the
documentary the first one the Sundance
one okay it's it was so worth seeing
just another friend or something yeah
because I'd love to know what you think
yeah uh the owl didn't but it's such a
ambiguous
not ambiguous crime the crime happened
it's such it's so ambiguous who did it
okay that I love True Crime shit is that
what you think
happens says more about you than the
case got it oh my God shit like that I
do too so with my episode on the accused
yeah yeah if you think I deserve what
happened to me you hate women it's like
it's my episode is about having to be
the perfect victim oh wow and that you
can't be a sloppy victim oh my God you
know what I mean yeah yeah you know when
like uh uh someone a woman says that a
man sexually assaulted her and you're
like yeah but like she shops at Aldo
right
right right and so you're playing
someone in that area yeah mine is like
in the sexual assault realm right yeah I
don't know when they're airing which
ones and mine you know it's like a
typical kind of actually I probably
can't say too much about it yeah because
you don't know the whole episode like
what's happening you know what's crazy
in the trailer you have this look where
you're just like
and I'm like oh it's one moment and I'm
like what the fuck like it was like it
said so much yeah I guess all things I
guess the expression but not exactly
yeah you know my face like so large but
it's yeah it was fun to play this
because it's something like I've never
done before you know and like for you
it's like a drama that you did and it's
just a little I don't think anyone was
gonna let us do drama until we turn 40.
do you think yeah I think also our
careers are just starting I love that
hot take you know what I'm I'm with you
on that I'm I love that I'm Gonna Stand
by that right Life Starts at four days
it absolutely does like I feel so much
better can I say something crazy please
do you're prettier than you've ever been
oh my God Whitney you're
I agree like because there was this
thing when I came to La that was like
you got 10 years right right to get in
to get the Chuck Lori sitcom oh my God
to get in all the Apatow movies and
you're off camera by 40 and then you're
an activist for a thank you for a fake
charity
it's true they do they put such a time
limit on it who's they though did we do
it where did we get that for me we I
think deduced it yeah from watching
Gretchen Mall Terry Hatcher baby like
Terry Hatcher was the first kind of tell
me if I'm wrong actress who had like a
second wind yeah on remember Desperate
Housewives were like whoa yeah you're
right women can come back because
normally you could just play a witch
Angelica Houston and that witch's movie
oh my God witches love that movie dude
we watch re-watch that movie I it's
fucking maybe not sober maybe not sober
is a trap it's a fucking that movie is
such isn't it like a Roald Dahl book
isn't it I don't know it might be I
don't know I pronounce his name wrong I
don't know
um but yeah it's it's so creepy and I'm
just thinking about showing it to my
daughter but I think it'll give her
nightmares it's she's she's three she's
eight oh she'll still have nightmares
this is what for her Labyrinth it's time
for Laughs that's like one of my
favorite movies of all time I was I want
to show it to her do you have I did not
see oh no yeah are you kidding no it's
uh look behind you up you should see
right above Mountaineer Nation yeah
that's Ludo oh my God
I showed them
Yep this is us what's up with that
channel
um I never saw that show oh really
neither
um uh but I like Mandy Moore she's I
love me I love like she's she's I'm
impressed that she she is very sweet
Chris Klein said so himself in his
audition for Mamma Mia
this whole show is like inside shit and
y'all what I like doing podcasts is just
say shit that no one understands but
they have to go decode yeah they're
gonna decode it's a verbal puzzle I love
a verbal puzzle because it's like you
watch let's do podcast you're like well
now I know everything they just said
right people listen to this and they go
well I gotta okay
good let's get Googling yeah
um we'd like to have a little mystery
yeah I like to find the balance between
completely over sharing and being very
cryptic oh that's really smart you know
what I mean yeah you can't like show
everyone your cards all the time not all
the time but mine are
black AMX cards
thousands of medical professionals on
ZocDoc are there to help you they listen
like a friend they give you the expert
care that you need when you find the
right doctor you can feel it you can
feel heard you can feel at ease it all
makes sense on ZocDoc finding the doctor
that's right for you is completely
seamless the quality care you need is
just a few Taps away in the zoc doc app
ZocDoc is the only free app that lets
you find and book doctors who are
patient reviewed take your insurance are
available when you actually need them
and treat almost every condition Under
the Sun with ZocDoc there are no alarms
no surprises
choose from thousands of patient review
doctors Specialists browse doctor
profiles you know get to know your
doctor before you go it's like Tinder
for doctors or like what's the dating
app Now Plenty of Fish Farmers Only what
do people date on now anyone YouTube
maybe the comment section oh good
comment I agree with you she she is a a
busted whore or DM me that's probably
that probably happens by the way
um you are going to browse the doctor
profiles upload and verify your
insurance information you're going to
get the care you need use zocdoc.com
Whitney download the ZocDoc app for free
then find and book a top-rated doctor
today many are available within 24 hours
that's sock zoc
doc.com Whitney zocdoc.com
Whitney there's nothing braver than
stand-up comedy first of all I think
that is the most amazing thing anyway if
anyone can do that you can do anything
as far as I'm concerned that's not
untrue but
um you can do anything except sustain a
healthy relationship but
um well that gets good materials I think
everyone and maybe this is something
I'll start doing at The Comedy Store
like just in the belly room or something
yeah I think in a safe environment I
think everyone should do it at least
once yeah eat shit who cares right but
like you obviously the only thing
scarier is going into a network test 12
years ago so you can do things I
couldn't I could not go I can't even do
that I've never had to do I've never had
to do a network test
I have some weird I got cast on the OC
as a guest oh because one of my best
friends Dan Levy his wife oh my God I
love Dan Rachel Rachel Specter
there was a time when it was like oh my
God you're gonna get this Josh Schwartz
shot yeah you got it and we're all like
oh honestly
she wanted to be a writer I mean she's a
writer yeah she's a writer yeah but yeah
I love them they're so awesome so Dan
Levy he's he's been on twice yeah my
bestest that's so cool yeah because him
and Josh are still really good friends
Josh Schwartz is my brother basically
that's right and Rachel and Josh like
went camping yeah they all they hang out
okay we don't Camp guys
camping is oh camping is almost as
sketchy as the lack of Maritime laws in
the Scientology
so a glamping maybe the glamping okay
um I just learned three weeks ago that
I'm half ashken really yeah are you a
full trip no half half mom or dad uh
mom's dad and dad's mom got it so my dad
too so you're not really don't they say
you're like not considered a Jew if it's
not your mom
Tuesday there's a lot of days around
they I just my deal is I go
that would shut most people down right
they say don't they say that oh yeah I
guess I'm not right I love it I love
that you're no yeah we're all being
controlled by this
um omnipresent all-powerful they like
The Wizard of Oz and no one can tell me
who they is they is but it's such a good
point so now I'm gonna think about them
like well yeah who the fuck is they they
say
maybe that's true but who's they what
was it a Pew study yeah was it an
epstein-funded study even my gyno says
soy is not good yeah it's not but I'm
sorry I was trying to give you an
example I'm like I have a day you're
right but Soy in moderation if it's not
g mode it's right I mean it's really
just the fertilizers in it and shit
right so if it's not yeah you're so
right the only thing my daughter eats
tofu the only thing worse for you than
um whatever GMO soy is just having it is
going I can't have this I needed some
milk yeah because then it stresses you
out the worst thing for you is the
stress and the cortisol you emit by
stressing out about the bad food right I
don't do that yeah I eat whatever
40 and not listening
okay interesting so then and um can I
ask what your parents did or absolutely
um so my dad's side of the family is all
in show business stuff I'm sorry the
business of business of show so it's
actually interesting to my great
grandfather was like part of the trailer
Department he ran the trailer department
for RKO pictures like back in the day my
great grandmother was a writer like she
wrote some screenplays my answer
producer they've been made
yes she had something like a canine
something I have to go do you have those
grips or know where they are somebody
does we have pictures illustration they
have them they have them they yep and
there's like illustrations of these
characters called the Yummy Yummies that
were vegetables
that she made this thing so she was a
writer which is cool I just think all
women that were writing back then were
trying to relay messages yeah I think
you're right yeah because in that time I
mean it was so like vegetables it's
probably something like eat this one but
not this one right I think everyone
that's like a had something to say yeah
and then they and we just are like right
yeah nothing no this is a funny anime
animation it's so cute wait all the
fucking yeah what's really there
remember Animaniacs of Animania of
course in the theme song everything
that's in here I mean I don't relate to
you harder I know this is mine and
you're like Lisa Frank like thing up
there animated Lisa Frank TV show are
you serious animation yeah oh my God
that's so awesome I'll give you some oh
please anyway um yes so yes that's
fascinating so yeah it started back then
and then my dad growing up like had
shows and he wrote movies and directed
so I kind of grew up around it which I
had him on your podcast my dad yeah he
would probably he talks a lot he would
probably love to come on the bike I
would love to talk I'm like really so I
have a couple things yeah I know your
dad is team light yeah my main
um
goals yeah I have a list of things to
dismantle and like fix Justice for
Shirley Temple is number one oh my God
oh my God yes this business was built on
the back of a toddler oh my God who was
three years old and like nothing cuter I
can't I loved her so much growing up but
like why in every movie was there never
a mom there was never a mom or a
babysitter there was never anybody Pat
can you pull up Good Ship Lollipop oh my
God it's Rebecca Sunnybrook Farm was
always my favorite Rebecca what's that
that's she's like lives with the couple
I don't you're right though she's always
like there's no parents
it's the one where they she sings always
like some man it's always some man it's
when she goes to audition and she sings
why is she does she sing Good Ship
Lollipop no everyone's singing Like You
Gotta Eat Your Spinach baby you know and
then she comes in and sings something
like amazing oh I'd love to I don't know
that was always the one I remember that
but I do know that this happened oh oh
boy so if your dad can help me find the
person that applied the black face oh my
God the shoe polish to Shirley Temple's
face by the way up to the eye like up to
the fucking white of the eye it is
literally this must have been Trudeau's
grandfather oh my God Trudeau's
blackface guy's grandfather oh my God I
mean that is perfect blackface that is
unbelievable that took hours oh my God I
completely forgot that existed I think
that's by Design yeah we can't process
no I think we forget things if we know
on some level we can't do anything about
it right otherwise it would just drive
us nuts to think about it right can we
pull up one of my favorite my favorite
jams
[Laughter]
because I am and look at how short her
dress you know like it was oh it gets
great so the so so Rachel and I know how
movies are made because we're big shots
and I don't know how to fucking
you know I don't know how to write a
check and get it money back from it but
you know so so I do need help with stuff
like that but we know that none of this
is by accident because there's a
wardrobe person the Wardrobe person was
told like this is how short the skirt
needs to be right and they were like I
don't know it's a little short and they
went well you're fired and then they get
a new one and they're like well we want
her like diapers to kind of show oh my
God and then they're like there were
rehearsals for this there were rewrites
of the um this was not a willy-nilly
thing where's a woman not one woman on
this ship oh my God there's not one
woman
not even like a baby not even a baby
like nobody
babies
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
why is it all men why don't you guys
play with your baseball cards I mean why
is it I've never noticed that until
you're pointing it out to me right now I
I know but why would you have noticed it
right be weird if you had yeah I guess
it would have been but it's not looking
around like too much but this is the
history of what we come from and so I'm
really big on like
this
oh
absolutely not everyone put her down put
her down
stop stop
[Music]
I mean oh okay oh now she's done Coke
that's great yeah yep yep that's
absolutely drink your Kool-Aid you're
Shirley Temple yeah why is his hand on
her on her yeah
like I wonder do you wish you could talk
to her like what do you think do you
think she was aware of anything I'll
tell you oh now they have chocolate on
it
move your hand
why do they keep why does hey why do
they strawberry cake or like why does
their face have to go in everything is
more the quiet I don't understand why
she's gonna get a tummy action oh right
I'll erase this for days
this is just what was on camera
oh yeah now she's sick I get it all the
sweets oh no no she's gonna puke
wouldn't that be great if she just like
yeah here we go here we go oh
can't don't have a book to read I mean
anything
[Music]
look at that guy right there that guy
yep that guy yep
[Music]
that is so oh
but I
what movie is this from which one do you
know
um I don't know I think it's
um what movie is it from I think I know
we got it on PornHub
[Laughter]
oh my God it's so it's a lot it's a lot
so the other thing is oh my God it's
just like a lot it's a lot so I have for
whatever reason I just went on birth
control 25 years I've been on birth
control oh yeah which is like I'm not
anti-birth control especially at a time
where our country is becoming like
Gilead so but it's already been elitist
anyway right I think in order to get
birth control you already have to have
health insurance like you're already
like yeah you're already yeah no it's
already yep so uh so you went on
Accutane when I was a teenager and was
dating like a 38 year old man and I was
like 15. it's fine I learned a lot like
I'm I know people shouldn't do that now
but if you're like from a family without
money your parents and they don't
discourage it
really back then right I mean it was
like 15 you're gonna be having sex with
someone should it be the brace face
video game where you open like with your
mom and stuff it was another
relationship yes
no yes they've gone along great good I
think she knew like this did she put you
on birth control I I went on Accutane
because I had such bad right why is it
like hurt yeah and so I went on Accutane
which by the way for everyone that's
like Accutane there's a link between
Accutane and being suicidal like yeah
the link is when you're 15 and have bad
skin you're that way anyway regardless
right you know what I mean yeah so then
you take the Accutane and then you kill
yourself and everyone's like it was the
Accutane it's like like re-watch Mean
Girls like it's just you know like for
me it was like I would I had such bad
acne that I would drive like my mama
dropped me off at school and then I
would like just walk somewhere else and
really and wait for yeah like that's how
but it's like that's just how
you know we're ultimately just Apes that
are just like right you know yeah I was
too embarrassed I guess and I think a
lot of a lot of
kids have like bad skin is like a thing
yeah absolutely we don't talk about a
lot because then we're like well you're
vain if you think it matters no but it
really but it affects you because
teenagers going through that first of
all going through high
ly of that stuff like High School's hard
as it is
not just being replicated your favorite
childhood cereals taste good but each
serving contains zero zero zero grams of
sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein what and
four to five net grams of carbs like I
feel like this is gonna like fix our
health issues in America kids can eat
healthy cereal like game over we're good
we might be able to beat China they're
going to crash on the sugar ass cereal
and we're just gonna be like boom boom
because it's keto friendly gluten-free
grain free soy free way to relive those
moments watching your favorite cartoons
plus it's only 140 calories per serving
it's like there's magic in every
Spoonful with over eight unique flavors
you won't get bored of feeling good with
magic spoon head to magicspoon.com
Whitney to grab a custom bundle of
cereal and try the magic for yourself
and be sure to use our promo code
Whitney at checkout to save five dollars
off your order and Magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a 100 percent
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any other reason they will refund
your money no questions asked
magispoon.com Whitney use the promo code
Whitney to save five dollars off thank
you magicspoon for sponsoring this
episode I truly do love you guys and
then there's a little thing on the back
I love these little puzzles
do we need high school dances no no
why no no we don't but don't you think
that we should encourage the students to
fuck
if they're having the conversation
openly but don't you think it's like
just cool father-daughter dances
that I'm kind of fine with actually that
I'm fine with in most cases there's
never fathers at prom chaperoning right
it's always like the fucking tambourine
band guys the coach
always boils down to the band teachers
so there's never dads there's never Navy
SEAL fucking dads like huh like what's
going on like so so when we did dances
just refresh my memory because I
I have a bad memory yeah yeah I don't
remember anything unless it has to do
with like shady fishy ass Behavior so
around junior year yeah who are you
gonna ask who's gonna
who's gonna right who's gonna ask you at
the time right yeah why does why does
the school benefit from kids being this
stressed out about who's gonna ask me
yeah it turns the girls against each
other it does okay yeah then you have to
go to Jessica McClintock and get your
job
I love that we're just yep
neural linking okay by the way but you
keep the tag on and return it the next
day to a different store yeah
um and then they go to the you know that
let's say we're senior year right yeah
we know that everyone's gonna you're
supposed to have sex that night right
with that person why is the school so
invested in forcing kids
you know what they might be in with the
limousine business they might or
whatever Hotel everyone's staying two
students like where like Houston why
you're so right though like I call it
yeah I I don't know there's no reason
Day picnic where they learn skills you
know what yeah you know what I want to
do what do you want to do and I'm I'm uh
uh you're
I really just bring people on my podcast
to bully them into being my friend under
the guise of like we're gonna save the
world I want to start doing a day a week
yeah with my friends kids yeah doesn't
have to be boys and girls right separate
where we learn life skills not like
survival skills not how to use dropbox
because that's gonna be there's gonna be
a different thing in a year yes right
life skills I love that song but we're
not doing boy scouts or girl scouts no
because I don't know what I have
questions I let me tell you my daughter
join girl only because all her friends
were doing it and there's like a Girl
Scout Troop for her school but I'm like
I'm not doing it if it's any of this
she's a brownie now imagine being a
black kid
how come there aren't more black kids in
the brownies oh my God you're so
much so right
too yeah I never did it and I grew up
mostly my where did you grow up uh
Virginia DC back and forth so uh between
Georgetown yeah mom lived in Department
of Georgetown yeah uh my dad like
Bethesda maryland-ish
um uh but grew up at DC DC and then when
I was 11 I went to live in Virginia a
place called Roanoke Virginia oh yeah
and then West Virginia in the Summers
which is where my dad ran a hotel so I
was just kind of like yeah I moved
around a lot yeah but you were East
Coast yeah chilling 100. yeah
um what was I gonna say oh oh so the
Girl Scout thing was yeah I I really
struggled with it because I know it's
like Christianity you know and I'm not
like
not not our thing but but it's Girl
Scouts so you're fine Boy Scout side
fucking be careful well supposedly Girl
Scouts like anyone can join like male
female they them whatever but like
there's no boys like joining Girl Scouts
and there's no girls or maybe it's just
called Scouts now the Boy Scout I don't
know it's all different I don't know
anything all I know is how about this
how much how much is it running you a
month oh my God it's not I know it's not
that it's more the commitment so we're
about to start cookie sales I'm already
stressed out so let me just let me let
me stop you right there
Girl Scouts This Is How They
thwart powerful women
that beep's not gonna stop me the cookie
sales is how they slow down busy moms
the idea is to teach do you want a box
huh so last cookie season yes I bought
every single box from Rachel Spector did
you really the day it started so it was
over that's amazing I would like to buy
80 boxes and then we'll never speak of
it again oh my God and let's teach your
daughter that we don't go along with
shit that wastes everyone's time oh my
God it's really like all of them so
we're done yeah okay we're done with
cookie sales okay I love that so much
what's your cookie what don't don't tell
me don't tell me it's samosas probably I
do like that
um uh thin mints in the fridge in the
freezer freezer yeah yeah and I like
Tagalongs oh
well they're not like the popular one
okay listen Whitney clearly we have I'm
not the popular one I'm the polarizing
one you are your Girl Scout cookie is my
opinion oh what's your favorite
um I don't do that kind of thing I'm not
gonna let you Corner me like that I'm
not gonna fall into this trap this girl
scout
girl woman Scout like I mean just just
um yeah I I think it's all fishy because
I don't know where any of those shit's
made where are how about this oh yeah by
the way how about this why if you want
to teach kids something why don't they
cook the cookies themselves yeah why
don't they do that and then sell them
I'm with you you should see the store I
had to go to to get like her uniform and
all the shit you have to get oh the you
know what that uniform I would check
PornHub to see how popular it is
so shorts only oh yeah no she doesn't
have a skirt she doesn't have the vest I
went to a I'm fine it's bulletproof
does she play her cards close to it like
what skills are you at you actually
because I've seen what like I just well
we're gonna do this she needs to do the
survival skills that you're using your
thing yeah and you know what we're 100
doing that
no charge
and you know what she can wear whatever
she's like oh my God okay I really I
really prefer this so much so um Girl
Scout cookies where are they made and by
the way what's in it are they gym where
are they made you're not giving your
kids soybeans but they're neat fucking
Girl Scout cookies
yeah okay where okay laying on me Bakers
okay let oh bitch
all right you're about to go Whitney
you're wrong
Girl Scout cookies are made by ABC
Bakers in Richmond Richmond Virginia and
Little Brownie Bakers in Louisville
Kentucky what
I know like little people
sorry sorry that's Oompa Loompas make
them
it's about makes it sound like and then
at this Factory I missed that weight
made by Little Brownie stickers with
little black midgets
that aren't allowed to be in the Girl
Scouts
but by the way that's how we know you
think they're letting that so oh my God
I know what you guys are thinking
like they're made in America Whitney
calm down right right Whitney you're
being a fucking paranoid so Virginia and
Louisville Kentucky two of the most
contaminated water sources no in America
oh
I see I don't even think to look at this
like I I yeah because we're too busy
running around trying to sell the
cookies what time with what time I mean
you're a movie star you're a TV star you
ever you have to say how many you're
gonna sell before to order them like I
have to commit to a certain number all
right
can I ask what do you ever like
um
like you're with your daughter working
on her homework and it's a nightmare
here's the good news if you can help her
you that you have to switch schools
in my opinion yeah no she's doing second
grade math and I don't understand it oh
well that you should that hasn't changed
so like that's the problem wrong but
here's the deal everything that we can't
do I'm quote bad at math yeah but all I
do all day is math
so you're great at math you do it all
day what time do I drop her off I only
have 20 minutes because then I have to
do my podcast like you do it all day
just not but I think what happens is
like we just are doing math we're just
like it's that we're like making
connections right and I think that it's
like probably makes me sound like crazy
and like a narcissist no you know not at
all but I just like I want to get all
the kids out of Girl Scouts it'll turn I
just want them to learn real skills no
I'm ready to go with you what happened
to homak homak I fucking would love home
like learn how to write a check you know
what I mean whatever the newest thing is
yeah yeah what happened to Karen an egg
around at school yeah
carry an egg around
us on a spoon that's right yeah whatever
happened to fucking um
climbing ropes yeah without male gym
teachers watching oh God while they wore
spandex pants I have notes on a lot of
school uniforms oh yeah our school
uniform oh come on yeah so yes but it's
not her school is like a small little
it's not there's no gym there's no
stretch but you don't need a gym right
are we stretching outside are we
Barefoot grounding are we like I think
you should open a school
hmm talk to Will Smith about that oh did
he oh what what don't I know
let's see I I just my dream in life is
just for him to smack me in the face I
think I can bait him enough I mean
I can I can oh everything that we can't
do we're already doing so it's like I
said this I don't know the other day
with maybe Katie on it's like I can't
drive stick shift technically and it's
in it I can't either but we do it all
day like we all day we switch gears
right you know what I'm saying yeah so
it's like I just haven't learned the
thing that I want to try like gin rummy
I like really want to learn how to play
the card games in rummy but it's kind of
all I do
right you know what I mean yeah yeah so
it's like I I think we sort of Shame
ourselves a little bit like I'm really
bad at math I'm really bad at this I
know I do that all the time you're bad
at like
the kind of math that you have to pay 30
000 a year for your kid to play right
like maybe that's fine that's okay I
think sports team sports is really
important I think for kids oh yeah and
we need to be entertained somehow like
we used to have Gladiator shows where we
would watch right like that's who we are
as humans right and I think for me I'm
just trying to go like what's nature
what's nurture and every day I'm trying
to separate what so if someone does
something shitty I'm like hold on hold
on was it their fault or was it their
contract with the universe because we're
trying to break the ancestral patterns
right like maybe they just haven't had
time to do that yet and they're just
doing what they saw like most pedophiles
were molested what do we do with that
information right
yeah like so it's like how do we just
like I just like I'm gonna say it and
it's someone else's job to solve it
right or maybe it'll just dissolve on
its own if we just keep observing what
we see and just like calling it out like
I think it's weird that these schools
are
having pigs saying hey
can you sign a Like A girlfriend of mine
has a kid
um and you're not allowed to have um
peanut butter in schools right right she
puts sun butter on yeah
yeah sunflower butter sunflower seeds
better on the bread whatever for a
sandwich yeah and the kid that was his
kid her kid's lunch he's probably four
yeah and a teacher
thought it was real peanut butter
took a bite out of it and said this is
peanut butter and threw it away and the
kid didn't get to eat their lunch and
the mom didn't find out for like a month
that's so fucked up like it's a white
woman champagne problem she can afford
sun butter right but still no the
principal like what the principal who is
it I'd love to know you know it's like
what's going on with all these allergies
like what's going on I know why are
there so many so I wonder this time
tell me I don't know what are you
allergic to I'm not allergic to anything
no no shit right I know I think when
things taste bad that means they don't
Vibe with us right or like if your
tongue itches like a little bit but
you're not like you know or if you're
just like I don't like this right like
oysters I don't care how many times you
fucking rape us try to jam a slimy gray
pussy down my throat it's not we're not
meant to do it I'm not I'm a Woods lady
I'm West Virginia Woods I can fight a
bear with my personality but like is
anyone think it's kind of suspicious
have you had oysters yeah I like them
with all the stuff on them and then how
do you eat them you just I don't know do
you chew them no
maybe I chew it I don't know you know
how when you I've had one only because
we were doing research for Two Broke
Girls yeah and there was some restaurant
that served oysters I never had it my
gut was saying no yeah just no these
belong in the ocean right these don't
belong here like by the way are you a
vegetarian no that's a case-by-case
thing I just try to go natural order of
sure whatever right I mean
that's a longer whatever like what your
body's craving is kind of what you need
right yeah and I'm like I'm not craving
this like I'm getting physically
nauseous even looking at these why is
everyone the smell I don't like I don't
come from this shit I couldn't eat it
without all the shit on it like hot
sauce like the vinegar and like things
like I couldn't eat it on a big vinegar
and big hot sauce stay in business yeah
because you're putting them on things
you don't need to eat in the first place
yeah so I couldn't do it without it
you couldn't do without it great no one
can no
but hot sauce is good on on a lot of
things but like why are we dousing
things that taste bad with things that
pirates used to have to do that that's
why a lot of spices it was like spoiled
like gross things yeah you're eating
spoiled food so you would cover it in
spices and vinegar and one sauce the
Pirates spices are designed when it half
and half not designed like a lot
um uh Boats were back to boats pirates
on boats used spices to instead of it
being medicine and uh uh culinarily a
delightful as a way to like make food
edible right on boats because they had
no way to preserve it right except
vinegar and that's because they didn't
bring enough women on board they would
rape them and just throw them off and
they'd throw them overboards I just ask
them can you cook something can you
pickle shit for us shit all you need is
why did they not ask the wenches to
pickle because they were too busy
[Laughter]
fucking um they've changed Pirates of
the Caribbean like you know the part at
the at Disneyland the part where like
the guy's like chasing the woman and the
woman's Chase I feel like they're
bringing up Disneyland I don't know oh
if you want to do this but in a good way
okay sorry go ahead no I think they
changed it the price is higher you have
to get in yeah what else did they change
I'm actually honestly Universal Studios
yeah Florida is
I've never done Molly
I don't think
drink a lot of drinks in L.A the big
producers have given me
so I and I don't know if I'll I'll ever
get to because now there's Fentanyl and
Molly too
right you have to know what would affect
me I'm starting to think I got three
surgeries on my boobs yeah and I woke up
halfway through no like twice are you
kidding and they don't know I don't know
if they just didn't give me enough or
and you could feel it I couldn't feel
this it was all numb but you woke up
because the crazy thing about getting a
surgery yeah is have you had any broken
bone surgeries I've had surgery from
like dog attacks what was that when I
was three oh wow wow yeah I have a I
went in a car accident an ear from a dog
but bitten off yeah but recently and it
was not recently it was my fault yeah
like five years oh wow yeah but wait so
a dog attacked you when you were three a
dog a beagle ate my face when I was a
baby yeah I'm not a fan of beagle who um
uh my friend it was my friend in
preschool also don't be a fan of her
parents I know they weren't even home
like I was the Eagles how did a beagle
even reach you how short were you I mean
Hello Do You See Me Now how did it even
get to you I mean I was three so imagine
I'm so short now and I was that little
my stripes mom should be in jail right
and the dog wasn't even put down my mom
didn't have them not that it should I
don't feel strongly like it should have
been put down but my mom it wouldn't
have solved anything I don't need to
like kill I'm a huge dog lover I'm not
we're all so huge people lovers unless
right so dogs are doing whatever they
were programmed to do right it was
probably either inbred or the other
three-year-old probably smashed do you
know the other three-year-old told me
that's the nice one that's the mean one
pet the nice one she told me to pet the
mean one so she was setting me sabotage
yeah is she an actress now probably and
her name is this is in L.A it was la you
guys start competing for roles
but a scar in your face actually yeah I
have scars everywhere a guy with a scar
in your face movie star right and girls
I know so um uh uh that is the parents
fault
um yeah because the breed of beagle
they're the most tested on I'm not
defending I know they have yes they're
the number one most tested on there's
like a beagle because they're the most
docile and the most forgiving yeah so I
understand why it attacked me we don't
train our children yeah to respect dogs
so my guess was being defensive was
there an older sibling too probably the
way they that people allow their kids to
go
doggy doggy and then they don't take him
to the vet and maybe he had a tooth
infection if he was older he was in some
kind of pain right and then they it had
enough right we let we tell people to
pet horses on their face
imagine if someone just walked away
petting your face yeah it just
disrespects it would just be so annoying
yeah it's just different it's just yeah
I just want to get away from you but I
can't because I'm in a collar but horses
the way that they see their eyes are on
the side right right so they if you go
like this they can't see they don't
understand what's happening right so
they're going to turn because this is
how they see you so the best way to
approach a horse is you walk up to them
you first of all just let them know let
them know stand wait
mm-hmm I I don't need anything from you
because they just interpret as pressure
right and then you go up to the side if
they want you to yeah let you know with
their ears and then just groom them in a
place that they can't reach
right that's how you show you so I come
in peace I'm going to help you groom a
part of you that's the first thing
horses do when they meet and then dogs
that dog should never have been loose
with kids no no they weren't even home I
think it was like her nanny and she was
inside Annie
yeah did the nanny where's the nanny
from The Nanny was from Canada
oh no I have no idea did you come over
on the Good Ship Lollipop she did that
like that's the other thing no they yeah
like women need to but like background
checks on the nanny I've never had a
nanny my mom helps me out a lot and I'm
so grateful that's how it's supposed to
be and that and I'm so grateful I've
never had a nanny and I wanted to be
number one all the time and I am and I'm
grateful that I was able to do that but
obviously we have to work sometimes yeah
but it's good for your daughter to be
exposed to other people and especially
right other non-white women that speak
other languages right so I feel really
lucky that
um my mom worked a lot she worked at um
she was at a ran public relations for
Neiman Marcus and oh wow Bloomingdale's
I know she was like a badass that's so
cool yeah but no or not we started with
fucking those uh we're good we're good
they're mine um needless markup
um
but so she needed help you know my
sister was is she older yeah she was
like we were alone a lot but she would
um get her rule was like no white
nannies not that there's some that maybe
if it's from Appalachia or West Virginia
or whatever you know but like because
she wanted us to learn another language
yeah which is great medicines because
like Blanca who like kind of was like
we're supposed to be raised by a lot of
women yes you're supposed to no yeah and
Games should be a village she had all
these um you know the designers for the
window dressing yeah stuff like so I got
to be raised by gay men and that's the
only time I actually felt safe it was
the straight men that tried to molest me
and now everyone oh my God I'm trying to
say now drag queen story hours molesting
kids like no no no no
I always say I'm just doing on stage
it's hard but I'm like I was blessed by
a straight guy oh okay I would have
loved to have been molested by a drag
queen maybe I would have the confidence
today that I've been working so hard for
because at least there would be a
Triumph and Anthem playing in the
background that would help me overcome
the adversity I was currently
experiencing
but like I think we're just blaming the
wrong thing right
because it's like easier than having to
sit with the discomfort yeah you know of
course no one wants to sit with a
discount
in an area unless you actually there's a
um ability to like solve it right right
you know so it's like the fact that you
have rescued pitbulls but are scared of
beagles like that's yeah
someone else's fault right that's crazy
crazy right because pitbulls if if
they're if they get confused they can do
way more damage of course do you work
with a pitbull um company person like a
um uh rescue at all or no she was
rescued from a shelter nice back in the
day oh nice yeah um so no not through an
organization in L.A it was in LA yeah
maybe yeah probably and actually Adam
Brody rescued her for my birthday but he
also brought her did she rescue him she
definitely rescued him but she like
brought her and was like happy birthday
I picked out your dog and I named her
here's penny and I was like Penny that's
interesting why do you really and he
named her Penny yeah but then I made it
Penny Lane so I had like a little input
in it so I was like let me just put my
something on it yeah yeah but you don't
call her that but but not Penny or Penny
but whatever I know it's there it's on
her driver's license that's right it's
your birthday August 25th oh we're
Virgos yeah of course yeah yeah but I
don't like believe in astrology the way
but I believe that our personalities are
formed based on our proximity to other
holidays
interesting yeah what holiday are we
near uh Labor Day so school starting
year five no one really cares about your
birthday right no my birthday was only
during school like one year and on like
but your birthday was like we're going
to Walmart and getting school supplies
like you're right your birthday present
was like school supplies do you know
what I mean like that my birthday was
the first day of school September 4th so
it's Beyonce's you know what I'm saying
is that her birthday you guys have the
same birthday yeah oh well her since we
both have the same birthday and we
my man with Beyonce
um I move mine to the fifth technically
so that she just took another day yeah
yeah I'll just I'll do it whenever yeah
you you that's you whatever you need
yeah she mean well she's like I don't
celebrate my birthday that's so fucking
basically I don't have time for sure
like that it's my birthday every day
bitch I'm Beyonce like I need a day
where I get less presents sent to me
that I don't have time to open and by
the way if I wanted it I'd have it I'd
have it like that was a weird thing like
this year with the holiday did you buy
gifts for people like what what's your
strategy on holiday gift buying and by
strategy I mean philosophy I really I
love giving gifts because I like giving
thoughtful gifts you know like I'll
really know people and I get I you know
get off on it like I love that I don't
buy stuff and buy buy I mean what most
people would say horde yeah I would say
collect like when I all year all year
and then put it in yes and then you're
with someone and you're like oh that's
who that was for right yeah you see
something special and you know it'll go
somewhere or you see something specific
for stomach I started buying belts that
were like belt buckles for like navel
yeah the Navy Navy
a belt buckle yeah from like the 40s 50s
right 70s and I started like hoarding
everyone's like when he's crazy like I
don't what the fuck I don't have family
in the Navy and then I start dating a
guy uh I'm sorry my sister's dating a
guy whose dad's a naval architect and
I'm like I have the perfect gift the
perfect gift and like
you can just bring tears to someone's
eyes oh my God like I didn't even choose
this it just it's just yeah it's hot
potato but that's a good that's a gift
in itself though being able to really
give something meaningful but but do you
need them to show their appreciation in
a way that is satisfying so like it's
just a selfish give no I'm not saying
that I used to like when I had trouble
receiving for a long time because from
certain people because I felt like I had
to because if you give me something
really meaningful that you've already
have done today by being here I just or
like let's say you gave me this right oh
my God for Christmas or whatever
whatever Christmas hot fuck you fuck you
the holiday the people holiday where you
give gifts in any that's every day all
the time who cares but also why is it so
close to Thanksgiving it makes no sense
we have two a week just to unpack a lot
no start packing again no it's Halloween
to Christmas all of it is way too but
since Thanksgiving never technically
happened it was basically just trading
smallpox blankets and can we move quote
Thanksgiving Canada does it right
because they just do changing of the
Harvest like they do Thanksgiving is
like oh changing in the Harvest we'll
celebrate when's last time you ate
anything from Canada
not there I know but like I was just
there for Christmas do we have an
embargo with them when's the last time
you looked at anything and it said like
made in Canada is Canada Dry meeting
this is an actual can
can draw
don't even know that is first member
Canada
Clearly Canadian do you know who sells
it Cost Plus World Market yes let's yeah
um recounters oh yeah Clearly Canadian
the raspberry the raspberry the all the
CH all of it yeah the peach no way it's
made in Canada but who gives up five
American bitch I do what I want
um it is weird because I'm like for the
first time ever like do you feel like I
think the pandemic kinda
I think having a child probably makes
you like crystal clear right yeah do you
find yourself obsessing and by that I
mean in a good way thinking about things
that like
like is this mattress flammable like
when have I ever fucking get oh yeah
like everything is yeah heightened and
in your your yes like everything like
okay well what is she eating like what
is what was your birth plan I didn't
have one good I was like I don't know I
do not he is passing with fly I I've
thrown a lot listen I better be coming
to the survival class with my daughter
it's all I'm we're gonna ask Google
Scouts Eagles
and guess what we're learning about how
to
um have crows yep leave your tools crows
will leave you tools so crows they're so
smart they memorize faces they do they
can recognize people for up to four
years love it okay so if someone comes
onto your property near you yeah or your
daughter and you go I don't like this
person and the girl's gonna fucking lock
in on the person uh-huh and next time
they come back you'll get a heads up I
need a fucking girl and they'll just
about right you need a hole I need a
murderer I need a murderer yeah right I
hooked up with Adam Doris from the
Counting Crows when I first moved here
but no sex are you serious so it was a
long December this year it was a long
I'm a fan though my man oh my God have
sex with me my man oh my God I feel like
we spend so much time
like Kevin Spacey pervert Brett Rattan
or pervert we don't do enough we don't
spend enough time going like like
fucking fuck yes
um yeah and I can't think of one
I know I was like crazy
Rachel's Dad don't even need to meet him
like we don't spend enough time lifting
up the people who should be you're right
we just did a quote roast I'm gonna
change the name of it to love bombing oh
my God I just had a conversation with
them about love bombing I didn't realize
I was love bombed until like speaking to
this person and it's a fucking thing I
didn't even like I'm doing it to you
right now you're love bombing me but you
know what I like it yeah but this other
that book I gave you called getting the
love you want okay if you have a second
I could just highlight what to look at
which is um we're attracted to people
with the negative qualities of our
primary caretaker and we have like a
neurochemical addiction to it so it was
probably stressing you out it was
probably like it they're drug dealers
love bombers yeah I'm trying to say it
in words that made sense to me right so
they might have love addiction though
which is their fault right or they're
just really mentally ill because they
could never keep they inherited they got
it honestly right we're all doing what
we were programmed to do right that is
true that is true program actively so so
that person just did what they saw and
what they thought they needed to do to
keep your Love But the irony is it's
what was going to right isn't ironic
don't you think she told us I mean so
this is
so whatever you chase you chase away and
I think it's probably I think with you
the thing I worry about the most is how
many people have had crushes on you for
so long oh God parasocial relationships
with you it's like Christina Ricci Mina
Suvari a little bit I love I spoke to
her recently I listened to it oh you did
and I think that they need to take
American Beauty off of all platforms
right and pay her a settlement wow I
don't even remember I mean the movie
she's like sleeping with well Kevin
Spacey's like in love with her or in
love with her yeah and she's like
teenagers really good acting because
he's only in love with underage boys
right yeah I mean so it's like there's
things like that where it's like
Christina Ricci like I had like the
people that I have on the podcast I'm
curious that your strategy of who you
book but I like
um
uh Tori Spelling I feel like
the
2003 to 2010 I just like watched
and it was no one's fault right because
so many girls watch the OC and and like
it was like my 902-0 to them right you
know what I mean yes yes
yeah of course you know and you were
like my Brenda Walsh but I didn't really
watch those yeah yeah yeah it wasn't but
yeah right I know that yeah I have to
get you home to your kid
um we're good we're good even though
whatever whoever she's with that you've
coached at school good good my dream is
a sitcom like I don't know like how you
it's it's so funny like trying to like
the notepad and the pen goes that's my
No but it's always like fuck you
I like Pat in his little room you're
probably even rolling
notes huh I'm just taking notes um uh
okay yes we'll talk about the sitcom
thing if that's something you really
want to do yeah okay fuck yeah are you
kidding it's like it's always been my
dream my whole like they're like What's
the Oscar nominated I'm like I fucking
want to sitcom the Oscar oh my God how
embarrassing can you right be like
actually what's more embarrassing than
like winning an Emmy my concern is that
we might like be nominated for Emmys and
we have to like we have to like be like
so I have to participate in this fucking
prom night
I thought we're canceling Homecoming in
prom oh my God we are canceling it but
if you get nominated I'm coming with you
wait do I have to get up there I'm gonna
hold your hand
after marvelous Mrs maisel wins again
with no female comedians on staff and
then I have to go up
and gone do I get to at least sit at the
table with them
yeah I think we wear clothes we've
already worn I do love that and Kate
Middleton does that did you know that I
don't know if I see a face totally by
choice my favorite is Grace who you
might have met in there used to be my
chief of staff now uh producer on the
only fans love bomb um ones we love Yeah
shoot we did a whole like thing about
this about like just the Royals Meghan
Markle all this stuff yeah countdown to
when she's on your podcast I will be in
the window oh my god
um wait are you gonna did you what are
your thoughts on all that
um I know we need two hours three hours
where are your notes on that uh I think
we did didn't we do an episode about her
um about the funeral about how both of
them wore their hair down in the entire
time they were paying homage to the dead
area the collars on the shirts too yeah
but the Noose is around their necks but
no the um where they put flowers or
ritual flowers yeah
yeah and they like went to like dry bar
or something her hair is down and it's
blowing and the entire time they're just
going
tucking their hair oh it's like you can
put it in a bun
put it in a bun put it in a bun put it
in a bun there's times for down and
there's times for bun outside in the
wind and at Queen Elizabeth yes she all
of the jewels are stolen and they should
be returned but just just said it all
I'm saying is everyone needs to set a
good example yeah so don't all I just
don't show women that on important days
you wear the hair down right I yes
thank you okay yeah because then they go
this is a big deal no it's windy like
you need a pony it's gonna stick to your
lip gloss it's your lip gloss whatever
lip gloss oh God do you remember like
not I mean the glass you mean women fly
traps yeah
I mean tick glue yeah
tick glue so so
um because also when your hair's down
someone can Jimmy oh yeah and the good
news about am I I'm wrong
guys how come men keep their hair short
yeah Mark you guys growing your hair out
besides that it's gay
you can buy your ponytail besides that
you're not Jared Leto start what Jared
Leto's called where where are we land on
that on his what Colt oh cold what cold
let's go there's an island there's a
culture yeah
because you've been mothering I have a
mother I know that's my job okay and you
can tell me you're freezing you know
child Poppy
poppy I'm really good at guessing baby
names you are basically guest
Sebastian's and Kate uptons really and I
was close on Christina ricci's real
close she has a new one I think I said
Clementine and it was like fucking
I forget I just saw her and she told me
she's a star fruit she was awesome I
really liked her it was my first time
meeting her no I was at like a dinner
and I sat next to her dude it is
important that that is being done yeah
okay so she before she came on yeah
when I like research people I like my
whole philosophy with podcasts the
questions I ask if I'm gonna ask
questions that no one's asked right I'm
such a fucking it's just that you've
already asked how did you get on right
how did you get I'm wasting your time I
like no I like you disrespecting your
time and your fans time the fan because
the way that they consume now is they go
to YouTube they get they watch the
accused they watch Rachel they're like I
fucking love her there's some like six
or 16 or 17 year olds that are like I
think I know oh right no they're young
you want to learn there's Generations
that don't know about us yet right even
though make no mistake we're famous
yeah but they're young right and they're
gonna go on YouTube and they're gonna
look you up and they're gonna see all
your old Access Hollywood interviews
where you're being fucking oh my God
being awesome what's it like just
fucking fuck the actor you're working
with well let me tell you I have a lot
of experience
can we talk about your breakup yeah
which one I would never ask I know no I
got so many stories I haven't like
looked you up much I listened to your
podcast I love that you listen would you
come on ever always
yes I'm
did I say it and you said yeah I've
asked you I know you asked me and I was
like
oh let's be on together okay well yes oh
Michael checklist is coming on oh good
you you don't have only girls right I
don't have one girl I mean guests oh no
boys and girls yeah I don't know why yes
well oh you see gender interesting no
yeah we do both hold on this is so funny
I love that you're having him on I've
never met him he's
like it's like meeting a real life
Marvel character oh yeah like a real
life yeah yeah you're like I'm in the
presence of okay what was I uh looking
for pat on the screen I had a Jared Leto
cult image up there and then Christina
Richie
yeah
I felt like you said what was after so I
thought you moved no so look up uh Jared
Leto Laurel Canyon house
what I mean I used to live up the street
from him you did
what's his he's a great actor great but
not a great person or what
there's a cult when are people acting
and when aren't they oh man great
question like have you ever like gotten
into that why is he Jesus what was that
that was his cult so he's in a White
House oh my God I've seen this house I
saw this house before he bought it you
know about the tunnels underneath
there's like tunnels and it's the
creepiest house I've ever seen in my
life and I heard that he bought it
I don't yeah why did he buy it Whitney
this house is so disturbing invite to
this house I so what does he do with it
yes oh my God it was the weirdest house
let's go to tunnels and can you push
tunnels right tunnels but he doesn't
live there right like he oh no he's on
his island with his cult what fucking by
the way he charges people to go to the
island I think it's six where is the
island uh paddle tell us in a second
what's the address of this house
I want to make some content oh my God if
you know what the only thing stopping me
what is I never have a pet
um okay so what's the address of a pet
uh I'll find out I haven't seen it quite
yet by the way I'll find it you will
find it isn't that weird that I've seen
yeah Brett lawyer not weird at all the
realtor so who uh so the 30 Seconds to
Mars musician had bought it before I
want to know the list of people that
owned it but what is the what is the
Mars island is a three-night
all-inclusive Festival experience relax
and restore with yoga amongst the trees
take a dip in the pool uh the pool laced
with Molly catch a midnight screening
gaze of the stars but do you kind of
feel like we should do it like
undercover yeah we film it yeah like we
should fucking this is our film right
what's the tweet
yes this is a cult
it's Croatia do you know when you're
accused of airing have they told you
January 22nd is the first episode right
I think I'm second because I shot mines
I think they're kind I think Howard's
kind of airing it in the order it was
shot okay maybe I know there was like I
heard that they wanted to do the first
one to be more of like a socially
current topic like maybe a weirdly
Timeless can we lose the comment so they
are Jennifer Coolidge my man oh my gosh
I love Mike White
yeah yeah my fucking mother and fucking
man Donald Glover my man he's cool I did
a movie with him back in the day really
when he uh uh which one because I when
he was it was the to-do list did you
hear that movie
um there's a lot of people in that movie
Die video which one the one where you
were on top of a guy oh yeah with Adam
Scott
I it was like a body double where I was
like I don't want to show my body so we
used like a large hairy man right as my
body what what I can't read you I'm a
fan
I can't read You Will Ferrell my man oh
I love Wilford I love hearing that my
man I'm so happy to hear that all right
I Paul the Paul Rudd he's so nice
Paramount plus is doing something kind
of interesting yeah so I want to start
being involved in more projects number
one pretty much only want to play
villains number one awesome right yes
like what's what's more villainous than
a privileged white woman at this point
okay and
um I want to
um
work with uh in the I see I'm getting
scared of them say the wrong thing like
Spanish
filmmakers you know like Tom Segura
learned Spanish comedian really able to
connect yeah because we're like only
entertaining right like the same right
bubble right like preaching to the choir
bubble yeah I want to like
learn more and be able to reach
different kinds of people and I don't
have to do if you're in like just in
your yeah you know you're so right which
gets me to the um sitcom of it all yeah
I'm not
um against they pay for this house big
fan of sometimes love sitcoms sitcoms
people are like they're they're not
they're corny they're cheap you're
fucking corny dude yeah like miss me
with that shit because sitcoms actually
are the most popular the big popular
shows on Netflix friends right okay yes
the ranch yes Fuller house yeah right
yes demos
good to know isn't that fun that like I
I do I like that in this game I just
need to think I just need to have like a
people are always like this Whitney
takes down women all these Hollywood
actors are taking down innocent it's
like no it's good you're praising this I
think I'm a fucking man like oh yeah you
know what I mean let's just yes
I'm with you I think that is I haven't
you haven't named any yet I know come
like I don't have any
just from drawing a blank here
you need to work with more black people
I need to work with more black people
yeah yeah I'm gonna think of it and I'm
gonna you know I'm gonna have my list
people
it's not easy to come up with which is a
problem
but I think we're just nervous because
we're on camera like you know what it's
the pressure I don't do well under
pressure
okay
we're just gonna we're going with that
take two
I can't I can't perform
um I think we're actually great under
pressure and I think we have a lot of
like I'm not trying to be pre like
preachy because I would love for you to
give yeah I want to end this with you
giving notes feedback to me on what I
did well in the last hour and a half
like where I was
and then
like not like construct like I want to
start getting constructive criticism
from people whose intuition uh-huh are
um but I don't have any credit like what
you've opened my eyes in so many ways
like the way you think and it's like
things I wouldn't even like start to
think about you know but they're so
important and I think that my only thing
with you and it's not your fault yeah
and I think it's like
it's how we've the way we sort of behave
unless we've actively deprogrammed we're
doing exactly what we had to do to
survive and win and I feel like you have
some residual
um
self-deprecation right not that
self-deprecation is always bad right but
there's a bit of like uh I suck at this
I'm stuck at this oh yeah because it's
been with me my whole life it's not true
you know what I mean it's hard it's a
hard thing to break though it's just
like a week but if you look at it as
like
like maybe it's not hard look at it like
it's not hard right why are you lying
it's just like weird to lie I think
that's how I got out of it right and I
went oh Ron funches fucking call me out
on this and I appreciate it was
uncomfortable at the time
but I posted in all my Instagrams were
like me being like Ugh
right don't like uh because I was so
ashamed to like
claim space you know because oh if you
do that you're a narcissist you're right
but you're a bit desperate right by the
way I am all those things
my big thing with sitcoms is I'll go
back to them when I can hire when
there's Child Care on set for real that
is the biggest thing it's it's the
smallest thing right the smallest thing
but the big like it's like what the fuck
so all the time's up stuff yeah
yeah we're all wearing black dresses to
the um or whatever why isn't their child
care on set I don't even if email female
producers and actors all of it it is so
so all of it but also Child Care on set
I want on my terms because they can't be
on set where there's smoke machines no
of course right sawdust and uh sex
scenes
open ones always there's no such thing
as a close one imagine
um uh
the babysitter is background checked
yeah it's not like no it's not like
the studio heads
niece right
you know what I mean it's not a friend
of a friend no it's like legit
professional like he's paid and she's
like you know what I mean yes and then
whatever she wants to do for a living
maybe she wants to be a cinematographer
she then
gets to observe right and learn right
you know so then you know so because
this you know look I'm like the Pariah I
feel like that's always like
inconveniently pissing off the uh I'm
like downstairs Downton Abbey but I look
like I'm not like I can go upstairs and
pass and then come back down and go guys
yo it's wild up there if you only knew
oh the shit that was going on right you
would fucking blow your brains out and
it's all under the guise of a charity
right he thinks they're good people but
the Charities are just to save back then
you guys so like whatever so that's what
I do but I also could be like the
paranoid schizophrenic that needs to be
like bound you know what I mean like
there's also some people would think
that about but I have to just take the
risk that
you know what when someone thinks you're
crazy
it's so freeing right because then you
can do whatever the fuck you want
I'm already crazy I'm already a cunt I'm
already a bitch but so the time's up
thing it was like no I'm where where is
the money right
yeah fine no one's I I don't think I
don't think a lot of people involved
everyone had their heart in the right
place it's just I was like hey guys you
know that um
like there were a lot of I think TV show
runners in it but not enough it was like
actresses which actresses great we love
them we love you right but they don't
hire and they don't really they show up
after three months ago so when a famous
actress walks on set and goes I walked
onto a set and it was all white man and
da da it's like well
they were all hired three months ago
right so I was like actresses can meet
fine maybe just go get like go on go
glamping or whatever clamping and heal
because you've been used right you've
been sexualized and exploited and used
there's healing that needs to be done
right right right and the Coco do that
and who knows what happened in your
childhood oh well yeah so that's sure
heal yourself but now the people that
like
know the production side need to go hey
we need to be having meetings with line
producers right because basically yep
whenever when only white guys are hired
that's a shitty thing to say like we
also can't be like only what guys yeah
they they made airplanes guys they made
air antibiotics
they like let's just chill okay they're
not all bad Jesus Christ and if you hate
him so much why can't you stop dating
them you know exactly why can't you fuck
up here like stopping a bull that's
bullying it is and I think that like
some toxic women have become the very
bullies that they masquerade saying that
they're coming after I think you're so
right and like what are you doing in
silence right what are you doing behind
the scenes from right you donated right
why but no the back to the child care
thing where why aren't these women like
enforcing that why don't they say hey
this is I think what the actresses would
do so so we're okay we have line
producer meetings because there's all so
a guy a wonderful man his name's
probably Jim yeah has been a line
producer for 20 years he always calls
the same people right because we're not
given enough time no no time he's got
two days to hire
120 people and he's doing a constant
Rubik's Cube because some are working
some aren't I gotta call this guy I
gotta call this guy
but it's all white guys right oh no but
I'm not allowed to call an agency that
represents what we call below the line
Downton Abbey that's a disgusting term
because they do way more than anyone
else whatever yes
um and many times die driving home
because they work 20 hours 20 hours
right with like no pay for what for a
movie called yeah Tremors eight
or by the way geely for jiggly people
are dying for jiggling so I'm like let's
talk to Lime producers they were like
boring we famous actresses only in here
I'm like okay well nothing changes if
nothing changes can I at least like
pitch an idea for
um
uh for the famous actresses what they
should not should could do could do I
would love to do this movie I love what
it's saying or I don't and I'm just
gonna get 20 million dollars to read to
maybe redistribute the wealth a little
bit right so when you take a job that
much money yeah you're paying people
right like who are we redistributing the
money to right I mean yeah because
there's a lot of white men that don't
have money and they're in fucking dad
too so how do you choose who get you
know like this is how I kind of I'm like
I don't wanna I don't want dirty money
and I don't want to be in a dirty set
does that make sense yes honestly like
it's not so I go I would love to do this
movie
um you know how the makeup and hair
people call and they're like do you have
any allergies like what makeup do you
use I go doesn't matter uh just half of
all the makeup in the trailer please
black owned
right and costume put me in whatever you
want half of it native owned good for
you though I haven't done it yet no but
like just even the to go that extra step
to be like wait it's not hard at all
because you know it's hard going on to a
set where you just feel guilt and you're
like why am I using right fucking Paul
Mitchell this guy's Rich
Shiseido Jimmy Choo we're wearing Jimmy
Choo Choo she's fine Tom Ford is fine
why are we giving more money to the by
the way the designers that won't even
hire us for campaigns right if you
haven't tried to put me in a campaign
I'm not I'm not wearing it I'm not gonna
do it yep Shinola only Nola Detroit
recycled only so it's like you know what
I'm saying we just keep giving money no
but it's just it's already rich
you're right we're doing it right and
then we go well we need more female
directors right right yeah
yeah but do you direct as long
no as long as we are
shooting movies in New Zealand right and
right
sorry Canada sometimes Canada a lot of
the time you can't get a female director
so when people say only six percent of
women were dark stars this year okay
how many were asked and had to pass
hmm I want that number right
why would they have to pass because the
movie shoots in New Zealand oh right she
has two kids got it yeah but she's the
most qualified right and she should do
it yeah so that means if you want to be
a female director you just kind of can't
have kids you can't even though having
kids makes you better even being an like
how do you know how hard like I can't
even tell you my daughter was three
years old and I went back to work for
the first time like full time
it was hell yeah I couldn't see my kid I
was in every scene all day long it was
torture thank God it only went one
season and it was like and then he wants
to go hey you shoot me out right I'm a
mom if you're not gonna have my if my
kid's not allowed to come with me right
because my kid's me yes if you're hiring
me yes my kids part of the deal that's
my favorite thing always okay yes so the
hours of comedies I'll just speak for
comedies not dramas the hours for
sitcoms Etc were designed by men who
just wanted to cheat on their wives what
are these hours
why does sitcoms shoot at five o'clock
on a Friday night
in what worlds see but I look at the
sitcom schedule as like the dream
schedule for the actor ah
and kind of not really right you know
yeah so it's like there's 200 other
people right you can't see their kids
can't see their families right right
right if they were getting paid but you
were getting paid fine right but they're
getting paid they're not dollars a day
and they're working in very dangerous
conditions oh so it's like I just am
like I think for me everyone I think in
the comedy community that that that is
respectable looks at me and kind of like
why are you in that fucking gross ass
business and I'm like
I need to see what's being done wrong
and I've been observing and watching and
going next time I'm gonna I'm not gonna
do that I don't need to come everyone
did the best they cope with the tools
they had and I think a lot of people do
the wrong things for the right reasons
right and we have to separate intention
and impact right right yes every you
know it's like so I'll do a sitcom yeah
when there's real child care and when
there's more time right so you have five
days to make a show which means the guys
that are reconstructing on a sitcom
there's rewrites every day right which
means every time you do a rewrite the
construction guys have to build a new
set overnight oh my God and then we go
you know what we're gonna cut the coffee
shop scene
and then they did all that and inhaled
all those chemicals right use all those
sugar tools and worked overnight I dated
a set painter and that was like it was
probably yeah how were those how's that
for the hours I mean the brain damage
yeah well we're not together I know but
what kind of what kind of paint was he
inhaling yeah exactly I'm like why are
you not wearing like a mask like why are
you you don't want to wear a fucking
it's like why do I have to do this to go
to work just right paint funds yeah you
know what kind of paint are we using
yeah you know yes we'll be buying it
from why can't we just make it so when I
do Equine Therapy with my horse and kids
and stuff we just use
um what's it called
um natural you go to Farmers Market you
support whoever the fuck is in the
Farmers Market local farmers not using
GMOs and shit right going no money we're
Russia has half the world's fertilizer
is that right which means we're going to
be in a famine in like two years
jeez is that true yeah so we gotta
pickle our shit pickle we got a fucking
pickle I mean you're in a pickle or jars
more jars did you just clap
I'm trying to get everybody amped up
about these jobs that was amazing jars
they're gonna like go through the roof I
mean everybody's needs to be talking
about they're everywhere this isn't
stronger when you're done with it right
you burn a candle use it fridge take it
out everything's a charge oh yeah jar
jar yeah everything's a jar jar jar
they're already near you right they just
don't look like jars I'm seriously gonna
start pickling dude let's do a fucking
pickle fucking I don't know how to
pickle you just put my paper in it and
then put in a jar but it's fun to do it
again I actually pickled jalapenos
before well that's your first mistake
did it yeah they were delicious if you
eat them just regular I put them like on
like chili awesome or like hot dogs
awesome and they're fucking delicious
awesome yeah I like to eat those and and
do hot honey oh and then in the morning
hot honey cayenne pepper a little bit
maple syrup in a tea oh my God you will
your sinuses will just you'll just all
out everyone's gonna think you're on
cocaine or something because you're like
fine but it just drains your sinuses I
love that yeah I need that because you
have to text me right now so much
crap shit in our nose right breathing in
the shit and then the smegma no the snot
is trying to get it out yeah and then
also in the mornings this is gonna be
correct me if I'm wrong
tongue scraper doesn't do a ton but like
twice a week gargling
hydrogen peroxide and spitting it out
just to kill the bacteria because all
the bacteria overnight when we're like
and then we swallow it in the morning
oh my God I'm gonna do it you know yeah
these are all like life tips that I
really needed it's like we all need to
just share them just share them right
you're being open and talking but
everyone knows like you know stuff I
don't know there's also I don't know
that that's true but you've had a child
I'm just kidding I have had a child I
don't even know how to fucking I did
yeah I pushed I know I pushed a baby out
of my vagina this is true Christ
it did happen I don't even think I can
you breastfeed with fake tits
I don't even know where babies come from
at this point how are they made yeah
well how are they because my shit's on
ice and Redondo
so I don't know how they're made did you
did you extract your eggs yeah I froze
my eggs when I was 33. good for you that
needs to be talked about more it does
but we have some issues what are the
issues very prohibitively expensive
right so it's not available to everyone
yeah but you're right but if we
decondition yeah purses and shoes if you
take just save up it's way more
important or have your um parents put
money in a like a money Mark put like an
egg account yeah and then every year put
200 yeah instead of it and you'll be
able to do it Christmas gift yeah of
like bullshit shoes right and you do
that yeah I think I think like college
is sure with the amount of money you pay
for colleges
yeah I didn't go to college but yeah
employers should start providing it so I
will start providing that as an option
for my employees I love that so if they
might want to do it if they want some
for women's months your hormones are
loans just function the way you always
function right it's a thing it's like I
was pregnant you ended up being four
months pregnant so you're just like
might have headaches you might have like
Parts you might like just be fucking
sensitive yeah and like you know like my
big rule on TV shows yeah is that no
one's allowed to be on a cleanse
while we're working I fucking love you
you can do that on your week off like
not you're not just eat in a way where
you don't need to go on this fake
cleanse right because you're you're
being
um you're insufferable yeah insufferable
that is absolutely ideas correct I'm the
brain doesn't it's not I'll just hire
someone else who needs the money right
who doesn't who doesn't who's eating
fucking in and out whatever it is if you
need to go on a cleanse take a good hard
look at your past choices
you all have to be involved we have to
look at your fucking shit your water
and then oh we're ordering lunch not me
is that okay we're just gonna is that
okay yeah no fine go for it I don't I
shouldn't feel guilty for eating ever
ever you're overpaid right okay you're
already pushing it you're already a
white woman I would fucking watch it you
can do your clients on your week off on
your week yeah the week off do it on
your time do it on you and your kids see
why won't you do it on your time right
because you know you know how fucking
yeah
it's inappropriate it's inappropriate
disrespectful to you and me because
anyone in this room can ever recommend
you for another job oh my God like every
when you go out for another job they're
gonna call us right and we're gonna go
great writer but but horrible judgment
but shitty yeah shitty can't stop
shitting can't stop oh no just like this
now look you've made me do like why are
you making me be a bitch right so that's
why I feel like in sitcoms like more
time yeah an episode a week is nuts
right 24 episodes an episode a week it's
a lot getting cancer and then guess what
the show's not going to be that good so
people go why does sukum suck well given
the amount of time we had right I call
it pencils down comedy because it's just
like we're writing writing we gotta
shoot and that's it it's whatever it is
it's there we've all compromised right
we're all bummed that this is the actors
have had no time to memorize it you know
what I mean like it's just more and then
someone said you know what the show
Louis is fucking genius fleabag is
genius yeah they they have time to write
six episodes right
yeah
yeah so down with it but like not um Pam
Fryman uh wait do you love her I love
her okay like she would be like the
missing piece in there she is she
wouldn't mind everything she's who could
implement this stuff I am so in love
with it what did you work on with pen
promise How I Met Your Mother I did a
couple episodes of that or a few
episodes nice and I was so in love with
her and we had like this great
relationship and she was one of my
favorite people I ever came up she's a
fucking gangster she's so fucking right
and she wrangles all the pigs she's
amazing like the most disrespectful
people she handles it respect her she's
the shit yeah I would do anything to
work with that is my dream yeah yeah she
would be the missing link pan Fryman but
she might be too smart to keep doing
sitcoms given how much she you know I
know she's still doing them yeah a plus
I don't know lives in nope Passmore I
don't know right I don't know I don't
think I've worked with Andy Ackerman he
did every episode of Seinfeld I want to
say oh my God cheers yeah oh shit he did
New Adventures of Old Christine that um
he's just the best he did yeah he's like
the guy so the comeback you guys you
know I talk about it all of the fuck
that is my face Whitney I feel like
you're just my soulmate I know I know
there's so much
um the fish
do you have a Valerie Shrine okay I have
shirts just give me a second okay so
there's a great Instagram about Valerie
cherish what
[Music]
um okay so if you haven't seen the
comeback it is please unsubscribe for my
podcast because it's like you're not
gonna get me on every level the pilot is
one of the most perfect Pilots cheers
close second uh it's so perfect it is
Lisa pretty good yeah is it easily
easily who's the woman that was in um
the crown who was also in fleabag Olivia
Coleman her Olivia Coleman Isabelle
huppert yeah I think are As Good As It
Gets like they're our best I think that
is very very best yes I can't it is the
monologue at the end of the season one
finale oh my God I'm back oh my god when
she is talking about playing field
hockey yeah and the thing in her back oh
my God so the what I love about Valerie
cherish and it's something that when you
guys are like she's like Valerie cherish
Lisa Kudrow too sure I had an agent at
ICM I won't say his name but when I
first my first meeting with like a big
agent yeah I was with like writers and
artists before that yeah and like
Paradigm maybe like like fake and I went
in there this guy Andy he looked you
know the ball in Big Trouble in Little
China no I don't remember the movie well
have you seen a Mudslide yes
so like if you just like took like a ice
cream scooper out of a Mudslide and then
magnified it like
12 times yeah
and then put eyeballs on it
so he was the head of the
TV talent I went in in my like kitson
shirt oh yeah I was gonna return the
next day okay and um
he said you know I don't really see you
as a leading lady oh my God that would
be insult if I was
um and best case scenario you're like
Elisa Kudrow
and you were like fuck so just know
every time someone tries to bury you
you're a fucking seed bitch because I
was like this and he rejected me and I
was like dude but I gave you everything
fucking Unstoppable right he thinks I'm
Elisa kudra what you don't know is that
is my fucking the only person I'm
respect in this business right so he
rejects me which by the way
um rejected me in the agency setting
uh-huh however if we were just at a bar
and he walked up of course I would like
yeah security would like have him
removed right this is the only
environment in which you you're you can
talk to me like at all like amazing
as soon as we step outside here it's
like a crime yeah
right wild yes you're so fucking right
yes so
The Comeback is the playbook for how
Hollywood gaslights women and men yeah
and how Hollywood
is the ageism
that is a Malin Ackerman the fucking
Juna in that that's right remember yes
the commentary of it like there's a
whole episode about how if you're a
woman uh who's over 45 and you go on
camera without makeup you're considered
Brave oh my God remember that's right
yes yes however Paulie G the guy that
played Bali G I had my sitcom he's
fucking genius my man
so like all so I respect you too much to
keep rambling oh no I love your rambling
everything you've said and I wanted to
say what you were saying before and
you're so right about more about me the
insecurity thing no but like I talked to
these entire time no you text me you
text me like I said something and you're
like why are you crazy like I made a
comment but that goes to I said I forget
it was something about scheduling and I
was like oh my God is that crazy anyway
the point being you saying you know I
still am stuck in some of the old
pattern of like the why wouldn't you be
like the amount of time you apologized
in on the DMs
it was like I was like do I need to go
over there Whitney I got is she a trauma
you don't for days but it's over right
now it's done right trauma's good yeah
you know it is good I am grateful for
all this that's why your child is going
to be so safe yeah because you're going
to see this shit coming a mile away oh
yeah no I'm grateful for all of us that
didn't have trauma
no embarrassing absolutely I did 30 days
no apologizing it's not a oh did you
okay okay you don't have to win it yeah
yeah so you just go
um where's all my okay fucking hell so
I'm with Rachel we're hanging out I just
came to your house
um
should I take my shoes off no in your
house we're we're acting I'm at your
house did I take my shoes off no do it
are you sure yeah okay sorry right
why did I just apologize why'd you just
apologize
okay so you did that one got it so your
body needs a physical yeah not a
punishment negative but just a reaction
too yeah you did it I did that once
right great yeah I'm at your house
um can you offer me some tea yeah do you
want some tea uh it's fine no no I'm
good don't don't do anything I'm good
are you sure
um or do you want some
are you making it for yourself if you're
already making it for you I'll have some
right we all do that you know what I
mean yeah we all do it and I do it
anyway I don't know you just offered me
tea and it like was an act of aggression
right
do you want me to have some tea I'm in
your house what's in the tea what do you
put in it
medicine or drugs I don't know do I see
stress why do I why would I need tea how
about this give me the tea about
Hollywood whatever you need so then it's
like and then I'm leaving I have to I
have a um uh my mom just died I have to
go pick up the ashes so I have to go I'm
so sorry
back to one
and then you're not gonna get the 30
days it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
it's just the act of doing it and then
next time I see you right I'm gonna go
hey I just parked behind you
and
that's normal right and if you wanted me
to move you'd tell me right hey cool if
I park behind you
yeah is it cool great right nice right
because two years ago that would have
been like I'm sorry I parked oh yeah oh
my gosh did I do this but I'm sorry but
your car it's constantly right
you know so it's just it's it's um takes
28 days to make new neural pathway 28
days you know you want a quick coffee
which
if you want to go for it
um I mean all right weirdo but like it
just but not apologizing if you're huge
if you're heartbroken ugh 28 days just
know that in 28 days you don't talk
about the person for 28 days don't talk
about them her him they them
whatever just don't when you talk about
it you're strengthening the neural
Pathways and keeping it re-traumatizing
yourself is if that's a word you want to
use right I don't love that word but
it's like but it's also yeah just stop
talking about it don't tell your
girlfriend but I need to heal I need to
talk to you about it 28 days after that
you can
that's so good yes read a book read a
fucking book stop talking about your
girlfriend and your boyfriend none of
which are going to be in your life in
two months right
it's not gonna matter get a life it's
not gonna matter do you have hobbies
ish do I uh non-work related Hobbies I
know I'm trying to think my kid is like
my fucking hobby yeah I feel like all I
do is her and things for her and her
extracurriculars together yeah swing by
Hobby Lobby and like Maps
yeah she picked up sewing I can't sew
and that's probably learn so can she
teach us to sew yeah for sure she told
me I needed to learn to sew someone told
you that Grace no someone was just like
said to me you need to learn I mean we
should be able like I just feel like
it's it's embarrassing yeah that's sad
stick shifting I think if we needed to
we could absolutely if like we had like
life or death
or like pickling like I feel like all
these things we can do very easily
I know I'm always like I can't do it we
can we totally can why are we such
programmed yeah but
why do we have so much confidence that
we think
that we should star in television shows
oh my God and that I think
10 000 people should pay money to hear
me speak and if they interrupt me they
get removed by security yet I just I
know so like right like a lane pick a
fucking are you competent or not right
and we're overly competent but we like
to kind of or we've been conditioned
like I don't know anything I know I did
that all the time I wanted to do that to
get help from adults right in high
school and drama class always like I
don't know like play dumb whatever like
and my drama I think smart people play
dumb because they know that's how you
yeah well that's what I did but now
that's over it's over oh yeah that's
been over a long time by the way if
playing dumb works on someone great
right yeah if I'm like I don't know how
to do this and someone tries to help
you're like yeah you're like you idiot
this is my Pat and I get along so well
when he helps me do something he'll
teach me how to do it right so I don't
have to ask for help again right because
he's sick of me
you know I mean if if someone if you ask
for help with your computer or something
yeah they don't offer they don't try to
teach you how to do it yeah so that they
never need to quote help you again yeah
it's weird teaching a fish teach me how
to fucking fish yeah but don't eat fish
Mercury oh Fukushima fish is canceled
fish is canceled with oysters all right
always Rachel bellstone
she's Mafia dude she's she's in we got
it don't ride elephants love you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]